now aside from fangirling tony fauci on
live television
there's nothing much jeb bush's former
flak loves more than insurrection it's
all she talks about she can't let it go
that's why with waning interest in the
events of january 6 nicole wallace is
identifying a new insurrection
saying let's go brandon this was her
reaction to an oregon man who uttered
the phrase on a christmas eve call with
joe biden
i don't know where to start let me tell
you why this matters um
the asymmetry has always been what
advantages the trump write more than
anything else and the asymmetry of
saying
f you to a sitting president on a call
in front of your four kids
don't
look past this don't look at this as a
story about giving air time to a maga
guy
this is the slow motion insurrection
jason in
in full color
a slow-motion insurrection victor davis
hansen is with the hoover institution
and he joins us live i see your smile
victor i spoke to you a little over a
week ago and we talked about
these
fads trends verbal ticks that seem to
take over the human mind many times the
mind of the left save our democracy
racial equity social justice and now
insurrection seems to be
the most
frequent and recent mental
tick ear worm
yeah i mean if saying let's go brandon
is insurrectionary what would be a cnn
contributor holding up the facsimile of
donald trump's decapitated head
or what was night after night in central
park
having a look-alike donald trump as
julius caesar being stabbed repeatedly
to death or what was hillary clinton
saying after the election that the
elected president was not legitimate and
urging joe biden not to concede under
any circumstances or for that matter
what was this obama pentagon lawyer
writing in foreign policy 11 days into
the trump term that there we should
consider removing trump either by the
25th amendment impeachment are a
military coup and military coup
was on the minds of a lot of retired
generals we had two that wrote letters
that mark miller should intervene we had
another distinguished admiral said that
trump should
leave the sooner the better so we know
what it's really about will we talked
about it that donald trump old horse has
been beaten to death so is january 6
and they're afraid of democracy they're
afraid that the people are going to
speak and so all with a month ago we
would talk about the theme democracy is
broken in 2022.
there's going to be a coup in 2024. then
we had military officers echoing that
charge and now we have the insurrection
meme but it's all a fear of what's going
to happen in the midterms and if they
were rational people they would get
around the table and say this agenda is
not good for the american people it's
not working we need to reboot and they
can't do that because they're hardcore
ideologues
you said something else that i found
very fascinating you said this is a
replacement for actually having a
positive agenda of actually doing
something that help solves the nation's
problems that in place of that vilifying
your political opponent at all times as
insurrectionists or as racist is the
last political tool of a failing regime
tell me more about that because you know
victor 10 years ago the obama
administration prided itself on having a
a transformative agenda for america now
it's more about
transforming your political opponent
into the devil
it was but even barack obama realized
that when his agenda started to fail he
didn't reboot but he did something else
he just disappeared
and he allowed the democrats and
republicans to fight for the next
administration
on his last year and he disappeared to
the golf course and you know what his
polls went up because he was just
disengaged and people didn't have to
hear his sermons
and joe biden is president and he can't
do that he was pretty good when he was
in the basement and he was not seen or
heard very much but the people around
him are incapable
as all you know as all ideologues and
zealots they're incapable of
self-criticism and self-introspection
and they've hijacked the democratic
party and the democratic mainstream
such as it is they're terrified of
saying to them you have destroyed our
party we either got to retire or we're
going to be defeated do something
different on the border regain
deterrence after afghanistan stop this
crazy inflationary policies they could
say that but they can't and so it's
either donald trump on monday
january 6th on tuesday or coucou and
destroy democracy is destroyed on
wednesday and we and you're right maybe
racism or homophobia or sexism the rest
of the week and and people are sick of
it and they're going to pay a price in
the midterms and they know it and
they're scared of democracy
right racism on thursday and apparently
it's insurrection on friday victor davis
hansen thank you so much for always
putting it into perspective thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else